anyway i'm probably gonna wrap things up
um
okay carl's challenging me wait what no
he's not unless he is oh he is
challenging oh let's play hikaru oh this
is cool
the sequel we're gonna go into a
stafford
let's go okay let's see his prep
he's gonna play h3 probably yeah
um i'm debating what to play i'll play
b5
let's go because if d3 b4 there's some
there's some fun lines
normally against lower the players i
play h5
but against zacaro this is the secret
sauce of
prep and that's the best move
yeah i'm probably in some trouble like
right away
but we'll try and make this work
actually no i'll follow the game where i
got destroyed earlier
against uh the bear person
so now bishop d4
i remember there's some idea queen g6
knight d7 to e5
um do i know what i'm doing though
hey rook i want to keep my rook there
a5
wait i'm nervous because i'm playing her
caro too
i think i'll play queen g6 here
okay with a trade
ooh so now probably queen b4
okay hitting the pawn and now let's go
for this and maybe some 95 idea
just trying to use the pins in the
position
actually a lot of things are pinned
the problem is queen d2 queen d2
is uh
not the most welcoming move maybe a5
here
yeah a5 a4 a3 etc
i feel like i'm going to get squeezed
like f4 is coming but then knight d5
it's still a lingering idea actually
i have to always watch my time hikaru
has really mastered the
the tempo
um probably 97. the problem is d4 is
[Music]
coming
rook b8
let's play this
okay so d4 at least then i have the c4
square for the knight
and then bishop here i have this move
that's a good move my pawn's a little
bit tender
protect the pawn
ah he's squeezing me okay let's play
this in bishop d5
i'm down the pawn but life goes on
i want to play f6 i always play i have
93
i'm trying his pawns are v-shaped
to play this move try and hop around
with my knight
it's a reasonable position i'm not
losing immediately or am i
c5 maybe yeah he's going to squeeze me
takes takes
what do i do here we trade
in this move hit the h pawn
my time is really bad though
okay let's play this and hope for the
best
now if f5 i take
that's a good move why is he so good at
chess
damn my time too
okay let's trade
i just want to win the c5 pawn hey free
pawn
oh he's going to win my knight though
i need to steal me of him
i have no moves
and no time and no rook on d8 ah
okay i resigned okay now now can i
refute his staff right now
ahaha wait why is he not playing a
stafford
he resigns was that raided
did i just farm him oh this is unrated
plays e3
what is he doing oh i guess we're just
playing chess now
i'm so confused
uh oh i'm supposed to be white
oh i see why he played e3
i'm so confused okay
now i try to refute his staff right now
um i guess i'll play the same line he
played
this h3 line and now he'll suffer
hopefully
now i know all the ideas that he used as
well
so castling yeah counseling is probably
one of the better moves
to go for this like 1975 idea
okay so the goal here is to stay up on
time and laugh at the fact that he's
down the pawn
um bishop e2 bishop e3 probably coming
oh yeah this queen g6 move
is sneaky
i played this earlier actually so i'll
play bishop g5 and go for queen d2
i didn't want to play bishop e3 because
takes in queen g3
wait if i beat hikaro and the staffer
does that prove it's just a bad opening
now i feel conflicted
ah okay playing queen d2 whoa
second lead syndrome thank you for
gifting subs appreciate that
okay this looks looks iffy but
i mean why not go for c3
really appreciate the gifted subs so i'm
up on time
um now i'll castle
oh no wait no i'm i'm okay because my uh
my queen's defended so there's no
knight e4 it's a little bit sus though
i might want to just simply oh what is
this move bishop here
he wants to like take and maybe perpet
me
so i'll play bishop f4
this should be better for me but i'm
scared because it's a karu
so let's play i'll play this move and
then knight e3
he's gonna play rookie six and
make things spicy
wow that's actually a reasonable move as
well
a very resourceful player
how do i cope with this
oh what are my coping mechanisms queen
d1
i don't want to play f3 queen g1 is so
ugly though
maybe this move that's also ugly
no offense to the move um
e5
you just queen c2 queen c2
it took a while to play
yeah so now let's get the bishop in play
wait there's knight e4
oh this might be painful
but it might still be okay i don't know
[Music]
don't hurt me also
94 bishop g4
if you don't know what's going on the
staff are just scary when you combine it
with hikaru
but he's taking a lot of time i'm trying
to calculate this line
oh or that line what is this line
what is this
whoa um
if i take taking doesn't work
bishop g3
i think i play this
guy i'm terrified now wow
so now we're simplifying
i don't dirty flag me
oh tricky
oh no my bishop or i have this move
no my bishop's trapped
yeah he got me
no okay
my rook is so lonely
no i got mated
ah he look look at this move 95.
it was actually a really like aesthetic
beautiful
kind of work of art this knight d5 move
well i don't feel so bad now because the
stafford goes to show the stafford's
still like
dangerous and at least when ricardo
plays it
knight d5 unleashing the rook pressuring
this
hitting me from all different directions
we traded everything so the problem
i should explain this the problem was i
can't play bishop g5 it's a move i want
to play
but it walks into rook g3 um
because there's a pin and it would be a
fork
so it's a it's a pork pin plus fork
so i played this move but then my bishop
just got trapped
again bishop g5 rook g3 okay good games
to hikaru he beat me
he beat my staffer and he beat me uh
also playing the stafford
so now i feel kind of broken